This episode of Shots of Awe
is brought to you by Norton.
So you hear a lot of talk these
days about the "Quantified
Self" Revolution.
Everything's being tracked.
We have metrics for everything.
We're extending sensors
into everything.
And all of a sudden
creating an influx of data.
So everything's tracked online.
Now everything is
tracked in our body.
We live in a world in
which human beings have
been reduced-- have been turned
into algorithmic cascades
of data.
And most people are
terrified of this notion,
of infinite tracking.
But I think the "Quantified
Self" Revolution potentially
can reveal us to ourselves.
It can become the
ultimate mirror.
Because you know
what happens with
those algorithmic cascades?
These observers,
human beings, will now
be able to see
themselves as structures,
as patterns amidst the data.
We'll be able to take data
sets of millions of people,
measuring millions
of metrics of data,
and find patterns, and find
spaces of interconnection,
and find emergent
self-organization that
is occurring on
these mega-patterns.
And then these different scales.
We'll get what Steven
Johnson calls the long view.
We'll get the equivalent of
the microscope or the telescope
for units of information
for data sets.
Who knows what we might
learn about ourselves?
How might we be able
to take that data,
and use those insights to
feed them back into us, right?
Creating that affect of
moment of ontological design,
where that information
access feedback
that further changes
how we act, and changes
how we optimize the
world and society.
The "Quantified Self"
Revolution is an upgrade
for this operating system, this
man-machine operating system.
It's human's versions 2.0
That's quantified self.